-Well everyone's talking.
Tomorrow night is
the vice-presidential debate
between Mike Pence
and Kamala Harris,
and both candidates
are getting ready.
And get this --
we managed to get our hands
on some footage
of Vice President Pence
preparing for the debate.
Take a look at this.
-All righty. Let's get started.
The vice-presidential debate
is tomorrow night,
and the entire world
will be half-watching.
We're talking
Kamala versus Pence,
David versus Goliath,
the cool girl in school
versus the heroic reverend
from "Footloose."
So let's prep.
Short for "prepare."
Short for "prepare thyselves.
A woman has entered
the mess hall."
-You ready to go, sir?
-I am.
This will be the most fun
I've had
since Mother and I visited
that grain silo.
-First question.
Between COVID in the White House
and the climate crisis
taking its toll on the nation,
what's the biggest threat
facing America today?
-Well, that's easy.
Rock-'n'-roll music
is a Satan-level threat
conjured by the dark power
of female magic.
That's why I'm doing everything
in my power to bring
barnyard nursery rhymes
back into the mainstream.
Next question.
-Mr. Vice President, did you
take on any presidential duties
while Mr. Trump was recovering
in Walter Reed?
-Why, yes.
I took on several more roles
in the White House,
including milk tester
and haunted portrait.
Next.
-Mr. Vice President,
is the American dream
alive and well?
-Well, of course, it is,
and I'm proof of it.
My father was
a gas-station attendant.
And his father,
a slice of white bread
that made a wish upon a star.
The recent economic downturn?
Well, that's just God punishing
us for "Animal Crossing."
It's not natural.
Foxes shouldn't talk.
-What do you say to young people
who think Kamala Harris
speaks for the disenfranchised?
-I say baloney.
The most disenfranchised people
in this country
are folks like me --
old white men who believe
open-mouth kisses
are a Chinese plot
to destroy the government.
Besides, I too have been
connecting with Generation Z,
and I've even tried
this new food all the kids
are obsessed with
called creamed cheese.
[ Laughter ]
-Sir, President Trump
attacked Joe Biden's family.
Would you do the same
to your opponent tonight?
-Look, I prefer
to keep things civil,
but I swear to Him...
if Kamala makes
any snide remarks
about how Mother has to burp me
when I eat salted chips,
the gloves are coming off.
-Sir, do you support
the Senate healthcare bill
that would protect people
with pre-existing conditions?
-I do. In fact, I have a lot of
pre-existing conditions myself,
including a tap-water allergy,
pajama rash,
and migraines I get
whenever I see a dog
that's not fully clothed.
Next question. Matthew?
-Oh. Sir, just pretend
I'm Susan Page.
-Who?
-That's the moderator.
-Well, I'll probably just
address her chaperone, but okay.
-Mr. Vice President,
a lot of people are saying
that Kamala is just
a more dynamic candidate
than you are.
What do you say to that?
-I say that's why I'm debuting
my new catch phrase.
After I make a good point,
I'm going to say,
"Now, that's a spicy soda pop."
-Jesus Christ.
-Is he here?
-Sir, here's a question.
Will you step down from
the vice presidency...
-Yes!
-...if you lose the election?
-Sir, please come back.